so you guys really seem to enjoy our
video about what if Bohr was a Herald of
Galactus so what we're gonna do because
Marvel's launching the Thor core after
the events of seeker wars because we're
basically gonna see every single version
of four that exists in the Thor course
stories I figured why not do another one
and in this video we're gonna be talking
about the what-if series what if Jane
Foster had the power of Thor
so this what if story is a widely loved
story among Thor fans what we're also
gonna find here is this this story is
going to be the basis behind the
theories that exist that the current
Thor who was a woman is actually Jane
Foster now the way the story plays out
if you recall our video about four is
much the same way that the original Thor
had played out in the earth-616
continuity this to say that Donald Blake
had an affection for Jane Foster Jane
Foster was his nurse but the difference
here is that in our original video we
had talked about how Donald Blake had
gone on a holiday on his own he had gone
on a holiday by himself to basically
reflect his lot in life to reflect
whether or not he should really say
anything to Jane Foster but in this
continuity Jane Foster goes with him and
so what happens when the aliens land and
they presume we're I guess begin their
attempt to take over the planet Earth
that Jane Foster in Donald Blake try to
escape but as they're both climbing over
a mountainside at much like the original
version of Thor in earth-616 Donald
Blake drops his cane but instead of him
going to get it Jane Foster is the one
that tries to go get it but instead she
falls down the hill and so while Donald
Blake is able to find a refuge in Iraq
Jane Foster finds the cave where by the
hammer of Thor is hidden and so much
like the original continuity of a
foreigner 6-1-6 Jane Foster finds this
stick which he gets frustrated over
because she doesn't really have a way
out and as a result when she snatched
the stick on a rock she learns or I
guess she develops the powers of Thor
now this is where the theories about the
third current Thor come from because
Jane Foster has brunette she's a she's a
dark haired woman but when she possesses
the power of Thor
she immediately turns blond in addition
to this she actually adopts the name of
Thor dysphoria ghin this is really just
a way for her to basically pay homage to
the original Thor the person whose
powers as she's gained here and so what
happens this much like again our
continuity from earth-616 and with
regards to Thor we find that loki
eventually escapes his captivity and
when he does he seeks out revenge
against Thor but when he tries to find
Thor he ultimately finds Jane Foster and
so as a result he attempts a ruse to
basically get Jane Foster to handie a
hammer over by creating an illusion of
the actual
Thor but when Jane Foster sees through
it she defeats Loki and she sends him
back to Asgard and so what look he does
here is he tells Odin that Thor has
returned and so Odin recalls Thor to ask
guard but when this version of Thor
arrives it turns out to actually be Jane
Foster and so as a result Odin it feels
as if something's gone wrong but in the
end that the hammer found its rightful
owner I guess the person who is most
worthy of wielding it and so as a result
he simply just banishes Jane Foster away
from Asgard for eternity now what
happens here is that that is Jane Foster
undergoes the process of basically going
through and and having more or less her
own career here that is to say she
becomes a founding member of this
alternate realities version of The
Avengers she also goes on to fight
various criminals and masterminds and so
on and so forth but she maintains this
double life of being Jane Foster and
having a relationship with Donald Blake
but also being a superhero and so all
this really seems to come to a head when
Jane Foster realizes that Ragnarok is
coming now again Ragnarok is a concept
we discussed in our Thor video and so
what happens is she seeks out SIF as
well as travelling back to Asgard and to
warn Odin but the problem here is that
Odin has fallen into the end of the
odinsleep and so as a result there's no
one here to really protect Asgard aside
from Thor TISS and the few remaining ass
guards who are able to hold off Ragnarok
and so what takes place here is they
eventually end up confronting a being
called mangog which of course we've
talked about him as well
and as a result thought is is successful
in being able to hold off Ragnarok now
what we learn is that as a result of
this that Thor TISS eventually hands the
hammer back over to Donald Blake and at
this point Donald Blake has basically
turned his back on Jane Foster the
reason being because during the entire
conflict he had ultimately come into
contact with Lady SIF and as a result he
had fallen in love with Lady SIF and
fallen out of love with Jane Foster now
again this is really more of a byproduct
of the fact that a Donald Blake was
trying to deal with having a
relationship with a Jane Foster while
she was balancing a double life and so
in truth she just didn't really have
enough time for him and so as a result
we found that once the hammer was I
guess given up by by Thor dhis by Jane
Foster and given back to Donald Blake
Donald Blake had taken on his form of
four but we had also found was
Odin had reawakened and as a result
because of the bravery that was
demonstrated by Jane Foster that uh Odin
had basically granted her godlike powers
had made her a goddess and so what he
did is because Jane Foster he basically
lost the love of her life in the form of
Donald Blake to Lady Saif and because
she was basically immortal now she had
to simply spend the rest of her life
without Donald Blake Odin had basically
proposed to her and she had become his
wife in this continuity now the reason
why again a lot of us who read this
story believe this this is basically
pointing to the idea that the new female
version of for maybe Jane Foster is
because again when this version of Jane
Foster gained the power of Thor she went
from being a brunette to a red I'm sorry
- a - a blonde woman now this only
happens whenever she possesses the power
of Thor when only whenever she takes on
that power in addition the power of Thor
grants us Bearer almost godlike power
and so as a result any illnesses or
ailments that they had are immediately
removed away from them and so as a
result we could basically see this
taking place with the earth-616 version
of Jane Foster who has cancer it's
entirely possible for her to possess the
power of Thor and for her to basically
be in a god-like state where they revert
back to her normal state once that power
of Thor goes away but again this is
really one of the big holes in the
theory it's kind of something that we
really can't get past here but the fact
remains that if the with the Marvel
Universe being what it is especially
looking at the age of Ultron what we
found was that as after the read I guess
after the events of age of Ultron
whereby Wolverine had effectively broken
time that Galactus from the earth-616
continuity was sent to the ultimate
universe and so the question the lot of
you a lot of us had was if it's possible
for Wolverine to have damaged time in
such a way that it being like Galactus
was transported to an alternate reality
is it possible that Jane Foster could be
yanked away from her reality to the
earth-616 continuity and in learning
that Thor could no longer wield the
power of a for anymore you know under
wield a hammer that she took it in its
place and because remember this version
of Jane Foster from this alternate
reality has godlike powers meaning that
or Menace early godlike powers but she's
immortal meaning that she could
effectively wield Thor's hammer because
she's already been worthy of doing it
she can breathe in outer space
since the reason she was
travel to the moon there's a lot of
reasons here for us to believe this
might be the version of this this new
version of Thor but again there's also
just as many holes as there are
supporting beams for this entire theory
but nonetheless this is just one of the
cooler stories with regards to this
version of four but if you guys are
interested we can jump into other
versions of Thor we can talk about beta
ray bill we can talk about alternate
reality versions of Thor what if Thor
had taken a different road and someone
is so forth but that being said we're
gonna go ahead and ring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed I know it
was a short one but this is also a
really short story she was really not
that in-depth but I will catch you guys
later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly